two of your dolls have gotten loose this
is the real world wow why are these men
looking at me
if this got out that our dolls were
coming to Los Angeles from Barbie land
catastrophic
no I won't let you do just one
appendectomy but I'm a man but not a
doctor can I talk to a doctor you are
talking to a doctor there he is Doctor
somebody gets security Barbie in cinemas
July 21.
[Music]
hey Barbie
can I come to your house tonight
I don't have anything big planned just a
giant blowout party with all the Barbies
and plant choreography and a bespoke
song you should stop by so cool
[Music]
Barbie
Cinemas July 21.
hey Barbie can I come to your house
tonight sure it's the best day ever it
is so is yesterday and so is tomorrow an
everyday
some things have been happening that
might be related
And my heels are on the ground
foreign
[Applause]
so you can go back to your regular life
or you can know the truth about the
universe
the choice is now yours the first one no
we'll do a redo
[Music]
you're supposed to wanna know I don't
you have to want to know okay do it
again Barbie
in cinemas July 21. hi Barbie hi Ken hi
Barbie hi Barbie hi Barbie hi Ken hi Ken
[Music]
[Applause]
what are you doing here I'm coming with
you
did you bring your rollerblades
I literally go nowhere without them